So it has been quite an exciting time for
the elements
recently. We had element 112 that got its
name
copernecium…oops hang on, we must stop,
I have got the
wrong tie.
So it has been an exciting couple of months
for elements we
had element 112 named copernecium and now
yesterday or
just the end of last week, it was announced
that the synthesis
of, element 114, had been repeated. It was
made about 10
years ago in a place called Dubna in Russia,
rather to the
north of Moscow, it was made like the other
super heavy
elements, by fusing two nuclei, two atoms
together. So in
this case they took an atom of plutonium which
has atomic
number 94, so to get to 114 you need to add
20 to 94, so
they used atoms of calcium which has atomic
number 20 and
electrically-charged atoms of calcium were
accelerated to
huge speed and banged into targets of plutonium.
Now the
people who did the new work which was in Berkeley
in
California had their machine running for 8
days banging away
the calcium atoms into a target of plutonium
oxide and
managed to observe two atoms of element 114.
Just think for
a moment, the tiniest grain of dust that you
can see, like the
dust you see on this table, will have hundreds
of thousands of
millions of atoms in it. So if you have one
or two atoms you
can, not only can you not see it but you can’t
tell anything
about the properties of the elements or whatever.
Now the reason people were trying to make
element 114 is
because there have been long standing predictions,
by people
who do the theory, that perhaps element 114
might be much
more stable than the other elements that have
heavier than
uranium. They imagined, or suggested, that
there would be
an island of stability, so you would go through
a lot of
elements, 110, 111, 112 that would be very
unstable and
then suddenly you would get to 114 which would
be much
more stable. Unfortunately, it turns out from
the experiments
that it is not the case. They are only stable
for a fraction of a
second and, like the other heavy elements,
they decay from a
whole series of different elements, which
themselves can be
detected. So you can see here the decay chain
of element 112
here and borium and a whole series of them
and soon there
will be another decay chain for element 114.
Now the real
importance of this experiment is that the
original work in
Russia has been repeated somewhere else. Now
nobody
doubted that the Russian experiment was correct
but it is a
general principle of science that nobody believes
an
experiment completely until it has been repeated.
When my
students do an experiment and get a good result,
I
congratulate them and then I tell them to
do it again just to
make sure that it works. But of course, just
because the
same person does the same thing twice they
might be
making the same mistake without realising
it. So if somebody
else using completely different equipment,
in a completely
different lab does the same experiment and
gets the same
result then everybody will believe it, and
so this is really quite
an exciting event because now element 114
has been really
quite well established and presumably soon
people will be
choosing a name and it would be very interesting
to see what
they choose and at this stage I am not quite
sure what they
might choose but I hope they will be inspired
by the German
team that named element 112, and name it after
somebody
who is neither Russian nor American but who
is a famous
scientist who’s inspired others.